[Music]
this QuickStart shows you how to perform
basic operations in datastore using the
Google cloud platform console go to the
datastore entities page in the Google
cloud platform console this page allows
you to store query update and delete
data click create entity on the create
entity page use default for namespace
and task for kind under properties use
the add property button to add the
following properties a description of
type string whose value is learn Google
Cloud datastore click done to set the
property use the add property button to
add a second property named created with
the type date and time with the current
time click done to set this property now
let's add a third property called done
of type of boolean with a value of false
click done to set the property and click
create and note that the console now
displays the task entity that you just
created users store data in cloud
datastore
now that our datastore is up and running
let's run a query and click on query by
gql enter select star from task as the
query note that task is case-sensitive
when we click run query we can see that
the results show the task entity which
is created you can add a query filter to
restrict the results to entities that
meet specific criteria let's run a query
such as select star from task we're done
equals false and click run query note
that done is case-sensitive and the
results show the task entity that you
just created since it's done value is
false congratulations you've just stored
and queried data in cloud datastore
[Music]